Who is
the god like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The
God Who reaches down to unworthy
people.
first Peter 2 verses 9 and 10
says this
but you are a chosen race a royal
priesthood.
a holy nation
a people for his own possession that you may proclaim
the excellencies of him who called you out of Darkness
Into His Marvelous Light.
Once you were not a people, but now
you are God's people.
Once you had not received Mercy, but now you have
received Mercy.
Maybe you've never thought of yourself like that before.
That if you have turned from your sin and yourself, and you've turned to Jesus,
he says you are a chosen race.
You are God's possession. He's brought you
out of Darkness into His Marvelous Light.
You are a royal priesthood.
Meaning you have access to God through the veil that was torn
and you have status before God.
But it also says you are a holy nation.
That word. Holy means set apart.
means distinct
different than all the other groups in the world a holy
nation. Have you ever thought of yourself in those
terms?
Not only should it cause you to think differently.
Did you also see how it should change the way we live?
If this is who we are should it not change the way we live.
That's actually the one thing we need to be reminded of today.
Like first Peter 2 said that Jesus makes those who believe in him
a holy nation.
So let's act like it.
Jesus makes us as Believers a holy nation.
That's what we're going to see in Micah chapter 5 today. So turn
there with me if you're not there already.
Micah chapter 5
we're journeying straight through this book and last Sunday. Remember we
saw who the Messiah was going to be.
Christmas in October that that this eternal Good
Shepherd was going to be born in Bethlehem, and he was going to
come to bring peace and to be our very peace.
Well today we'll see as those people heard that message. They
they knew that was still future so they had to wait.
And what we'll see today is what they were to do as they
waited how they should trust that Yahweh
Messiah.
What they had to do is they waited.
This is Micah 5 starting in verse 5. We say it's verse
5 b second line down through the end of
verse 15.
It says when the Assyrian comes into our land and shreds in
our palaces, then we'll raise against him Seven Shepherds and eight
princes of men.
And they shall Shepherd the land of Assyria with the sword with the
land of nimrod at its entrances and he shall deliver
us from the Assyrian when he comes into our land and Treads within
our border.
Then the remnant of Jacob shall be in the midst of many peoples like
do from the Lord like showers on the
grass, which delay not for a man nor wait for the children of
man.
And the remnant of Jacob shall be among the nations in the
midst of many people's.
Like a lion among the beasts of the forest like a young
lion among the flocks of sheep, which when it goes through Treads down
and tears and pieces and there's none to deliver.
Your hand shall be lifted up over your adversaries and all
your enemies shall be cut off.
And in that day declares the Lord I will cut off your horses from
among you and destroy your chariots. I will cut off
the cities of your land and throw down your strongholds. I
will cut off sorceries from your hand and you shall have no more
tellers of Fortunes.
And I will cut off your carved images and your pillars from
among you.
And you shall bow down no more.
To the work of your hands.
And I will root out your Asher images from among you and
destroy your cities.
And in anger and wrath I will execute Vengeance on
the Nations that did not obey.
This is the word of the Lord.
So God, we pray that you would open our eyes to understand it.
To apply it to our lives not just
to look at it as a theological textbook but to understand what
you're trying to say even to us today. Help us see that
with our hearts.
And change our lives.
Jesus name we pray.
amen
And so as they waited for this Messiah to come they had
to trust yahwe to do a few things.
They had to trust that he was going to do a few things as they
waited. Well, what were the things they waited for? Well first
they trusted him to deliver his people
first.
to deliver his people
That's what Micah was declaring here this deliverance from
these Assyrians trying to overtake Judah they were they were coming
into the land and and that they trusted Yahweh would deliver
them in his time and his way and they knew
it was gonna be God who did that?
Because what did we just come off of the last
five verses right this idea of a messiah
the strong Shepherd in verses 2
through 5. God was going to be this verse 6
deliver. He would be the one to deliver
his people.
That's even what he's saying here with these Seven Shepherds and eight princes.
It's evidence that God is going to provide more than
enough power to overcome the enemy because in
Hebrew writings, that's how it would work if they say a number and then
repeat a one step higher or a larger number. It
shows that it's just illustrating enough sufficiency.
So God says I'm going to give you enough power to overcome.
So even though they're facing the grave danger a
syrians coming in their land. They knew what they couldn't fight them themselves.
They could trust Yahweh would deliver them in his
time his way with his power.
So they waited for deliverance, but they also waited and
they trusted Yahweh in that waiting to bless all people.
deliver them
and bless all people.
To bless the Nations through them. That's what
they were waiting and trusting him to do look again at verse
7.
Says the remnant of Jacob shall be in the midst of many peoples like
do from the Lord showers on the grass, which delay not
for man nor wait for the children of man.
Now as you read commentators and Scholars,
there's some debate over this section right here how to read
it. Well and I agree. It's pretty tricky had to spend some time
on it. But the best I can understand is what they're talking about here is positive.
What Micah says here is a positive thing? Because every time do and
showers from the Lord appear in God's
word. It's a positive thing.
Like for those who receive it it's refreshing. It's a good
thing to have do and showers.
so somehow
even though this remnant of God's people would be scattered
among the nations in Exile.
They were still gonna bless the nations in the midst of that.
It's not the first time we see this.
It's actually Jeremiah 29 verses 5 through
7. We're he's speaking to the Exiles in Babylon what
they were to do while they're in Exile
says this
Jeremiah 29:5-7 build houses
and live in them plant Gardens
eat their produce take wives have sons and daughters
take wives for your sons. Give your daughters in marriage that they may
bear Sons and Daughters multiply there.
Do not decrease.
But seek the welfare of the city in which I
have sent you into exile.
And pray to the Lord on its behalf for in
its welfare. You will find your welfare.
Now just in a few verses later God promised us to deliver
them after 70 years. He's going to bring it back to their land. But while
they waited.
While they were waiting for deliverance, they were to live and bless
their neighbors.
Even there in Exile.
They were to be a blessing which is really a continuation of God's covenant
with Abraham back in Genesis 12. He said you're gonna be a blessing
to all the families of the earth. It tracks through all the
way to God's people being a blessing to All Nations.
But just think about that for a second, that's a tough ask, right.
I mean, they're in a hostile culture. Everything is against
Yahweh different practices different culture. That's
why verse 7 ended with this phrase about delaying and
waiting. That's one of the complicated parts of this.
It doesn't delay. It doesn't wait for the children a man. What Micah meant
here. Is that just like you cannot make do
or Reign? Come on the Earth?
You can't do this either.
Do and rain is God's job the same thing
with this only he can do this through you as well.
It seems impossible to be a blessing while in
Exile
And hostile culture it's very difficult. So you
got to trust God to do it.
Got to trust God to do it through you.
So they were waiting and trusting God to be a blessing to
others.
But do you remember what verse 8 said of Micah 5
it wasn't all blessing for those around them, right?
Yes there to be a blessing but as the remnant is scattered.
God will actually bring judgment.
as well
In fact, he uses this illustration of a lion with
sheep and he uses that to say he will condemn some
people.
Yeah, they're gonna be a blessing as they go and they're going to bless the
Nations. Yes, but
there's also going to be judgment. He's going to condemn some verse
9 Micah says to God the tent
says to God that your hand shall be lifted up over your adversaries
your enemies.
It's a Victorious language verse 15. God says I will execute
judge Vengeance on the nation's.
So yes blessing but also judgment, but
don't think revenge.
The word vengeance is so close to Revenge. We think immediately
that God's taken revenge on his enemies. No, this is
the the idea of the wording here is that this is like a leader protecting
his people by getting rid
of the troublemakers and those who are slaying his people even
in the land.
Like so this is a positive idea that he's saying I'm
to protect my people.
Your trouble your trouble get out.
That's the idea of these vengeance is coming.
And that's been a consistent theme throughout Micah, right?
That there are people who are not.
Following Yahweh. They're turning their backs on God. They don't
listen and they don't obey and they're going to be judged by
that doesn't matter what the name on their their name plate
is it's still judgment is coming.
And so the remnant had to wait on Yahweh to bring that Justice, right?
God repeatedly says over and over I'm going to be the one to judge.
I'm going to judge. I'm going to judge.
in his time and his way he would bring that but they had
to have confidence that he was going to
because they see what you see right? They
see what what Carnage was happening around them as they were
oppressing the poor and and favoring the rich and Injustice all
over the place and they were looking at it like God do something.
and he says I'm going to
that's part of what they're waiting on here. But there's
there's something else they're waiting on here.
The verses 10 through 14 show us that they're
waiting and trusting God to do one more
thing in this.
That he would purify his people.
It kind of goes with what we just talked about this judgment on those even in
the in the land who were Injustice in
their life. And so here they're waiting
on God to purify his people purify them.
Look at verses 10 through 14 again.
In that day again that's referring to the day
of the Messiah in that day declares the Lord. I will
cut off your horses from among you destroy your chariots cut off
the cities of your land throw down your strongholds cut off sorceries from
your hand. No more tellers of Fortunes cut off
a carved images your pillars bow down no more
to the work of your hands. I'll root out your Astra images destroy your
cities. Did you see
How many times it said I will I will I
will God is saying that to his people
nine times. He says I will do this. I will
do this God is talking to his people verse
15. He talks to the Nations said vengeance is
coming to you. But in these verses he says I will
do this and I will do this.
In verse 9. He says I'm gonna cut off my enemies
here in verses 10 through 14. He
says I'm going to cut off all of these things.
in his people
And he lists out all these things. So think about what this would have
meant to his people to those who are hearing this.
He says horses and chariots.
That signified military might that they
were trusting in.
The cities and the strongholds would illustrate
this this engineering ingenuity.
That they had because they were having these thick walls.
They were safe because of their their minds.
The sorceries the fortune tellers the carved images
the ashra pillars.
It's all just wrapped around this idea of false religions
and Idols that they were trusting in.
And so what God is saying here they had to hear this what God
is saying is he was about to comb through their nation and
make them holy again.
They had all these other things they were trusting and all these other idols.
And God says I'm about to make you holy again
because remember that's what they were intended to be, right.
That's what they were supposed to be. It's from the
Covenant God initiated with Moses and with his people
on the Mount Sinai back in Exodus 19.
This is Verses 4 through 6. Listen to What God Says You
yourselves have seen what I did to the Egyptians how
I bore You On Eagle's Wings brought you to myself.
Now therefore if you will indeed obey my voice and keep my
Covenant.
You shall be my treasured possession among all
peoples for all the Earth is mine.
And you shall be to me a kingdom of priests?
and a holy nation
it sounds a whole like what I started with in First Peter 2, right. Do
you think where we got that now, huh?
But this was God's whole point in choosing Israel
to be his people was to set them apart and
say this is different.
This is who I am by looking at this group of
people.
But the whole book of Micah has shown us that they failed to
live like that. They began to live
just like the rest of the world.
They began to look not distinct not
set apart and look just like everyone else even
verse 13 says they're bowing down to the
work of their own hands.
How futile is that?
and so Messiah when Messiah comes
like the the water filter in your fridge, he's going to
start purifying out all the junk that's going to destroy you.
So that you can live like he wants you to live.
So you can be holy you can be set apart. That's
what his intention was.
But the question then comes forward to us.
So that's what God was saying to them. That was
what they were waiting for in the kingdom of God that was coming. This
is what it would look like as God would come but
what about us today?
Really, aren't we doing much the same thing?
In you know, we'll get to some of the things that we're doing. But but aren't we
in the same boat here? Because because think about how we're waiting.
This Messiah is still in some
way future. Yes, the kingdom has already come in Jesus,
but he has not yet. Come to fully complete
his kingdom.
So we're in this waiting game. We're in between we're looking forward
to something. That's still future. You might
say we are still an exile.
That we are not home yet.
This has great or as poor as it
is is not home for us.
God is still coming back one day to take us home. He's
preparing a place for us that we might be in his
Promised Land again.
And so the question then is how do we live out these
principles today?
If we can kind of take a bit of a parallel between them and
us today, how do we live this out then?
How do we take steps forward to
apply Micah 5?
To our lives today.
How do we wait you might ask?
Well, here's how we do it first.
Like Judah remember was supposed to be due and rain showers
for the Nations around them even among hostile
Nations while they were in Exile.
We also are to bless
others as we wait for full Deliverance in Jesus.
How do we wait?
How do we how do we wait like they had to wait for
the Messiah? Well first we bless others.
Just like this we bless others.
Now I was trying to think of some examples of this think of the
first church.
Acts 2 Church began, what did they
do? Because they were not in a friendly area. It's
very hostile the place they were living they
were threatened with death repeatedly, but what
did they do?
They were loving people healing people they were
providing for widows. They were taking an orphans. They
were walking in when the plagues happened while everybody else was
walking out. They were blessing the people that they
lived around even as the hostility came
in.
And so think but but also think about the last
2,000 years since then.
And I know the church has a pretty checkered past as we look back
at those two thousand years, but think how many schools and
hospitals and social agencies
have been started by the church churches.
and so we hear this we as God's
Believing. Holy nation his holy people.
We are not meant to run
away from the world around us.
We are to bless the world around us as
much as we possibly can.
Remember Jeremiah 29. They're an exile that Micah 5
you're going to be an exile. You're gonna be do you're gonna be Showers of
rain. We have to think like ambassadors to
a foreign Nation.
Because this is not home. We're in a foreign Nation right
now. And so we have the the thought process like
an ambassador which by the way God has graciously compassionately
called us to be
Like what an honor that is, right?
To be called an ambassador of the kingdom of God called by the
king himself to be your representative to
a foreign Nation.
What is an ambassador do?
remember an ambassador is supposed to remain unstained by
the negative parts of that country that they're going
to
Right, they're not to get immersed into it and and be taken away
from the principles of their home country. They're not supposed
to do that. They're supposed to stay away in some
sense separated from it.
But also
they are to bring the best parts of their home country to
bear on the new country, right?
It's an ambassador. Does that's us to
the World Church?
We are to bless the world around
us to take the kingdom principles and
apply them to our lives as much as we can.
That's one way we can wait.
On God's full Kingdom to come as we're in this Exile. We
wait for him. We also wait in that
by putting our trust in Yahweh.
Just like they had to
we rely on Yahweh to
do what he's promised to do.
It's called Trust.
And that's what that is. It's a Reliance that God you've
said you're going to do this. So I'm trusting you're going to it's trusting him.
And so as we're in this Exile this hostile hostile
world.
What do we do when we're threatened?
They were pressed in on every side. What are we to do
when we are pressed in with evil forces around us do
we fight?
Do we hide?
Listen to how Romans 12.
verses 14 through 21 says
we are to do it bless those who persecute you.
Bless and do not curse them.
Rejoice with those who Rejoice weep with those
who weep live in harmony with one another do not be prideful but
associate with the lowly
never be wise in your own sight.
Repay, no one evil for evil.
But give thought to do what is Honorable in the sight of all.
if possible so far as it depends on you live peaceably with
all
Beloved never avenge yourselves but
leave it to the wrath of God for it is written vengeance
is mine. I will repay says the Lord.
To the contrary if your enemy is hungry feed
him.
If he's thirsty give him something to drink for by so doing
you'll keep burning coals on his head.
And do not be overcome by evil but overcome evil with
good.
See if we remember that vengeance is not ours.
It's God's.
That's how then we're able to bless.
That's how we're able to rejoice and weep with
people who don't believe what we believe.
That's how we're able to walk humbly to not take
revenge to give food and water to our enemies
to overcome evil with good. That's how we do
it because we know we're trusting God to make it.
All right that's wrong right now.
We're trusting God to make all that is wrong right at
some point now. Yes, we're agents of that at times
but we are never to do that with vengeance in
our hearts.
Because it's his.
It's trusting God the way of
the Cross is utterly different than the way of the world.
Is trusting him to work it out.
Not try to work it out ourselves.
But there's one more.
We started with the main
point today.
How we wait is also by seeking holiness.
We seek holiness.
again, if God has made us
As his people a holy nation his holy people.
Then let's act like it.
Let's be different like that.
I started with first Peter 2 verses 9 and 10. He continues
in verses 11 and 12 listen to this.
He says beloved, I urge you as sojourners and
exiles.
We are Exiles I urge you to abstain from the
passions of the flesh.
Which wage war against your soul?
Keep your conduct among the Gentiles honorable.
So that when they speak against you as evildoers, they may
see your good deeds and glorify God on the
day of visitation.
You see that?
It's not so they glorify you. It's so they glorify God they see you
live differently.
For the sake of God's glory.
Okay. So seek Holiness a very broad term very large bucket.
How do we do that?
Well, Micah 5 shows us a few things.
That we seek holiness.
first by not seeking worldly power
Micah 5 says seek Holiness not worldly power.
Remember what Judah was trusting in?
The things God was stripping away as he combed through
the nation. What was they trusting in first? They were trusting in their military strength
the size of their City walls, right?
They were trusting in these things to protect them from the
enemy not God himself to protect them.
We Face similar Temptations every day, don't we?
Do we feel secure?
In our lives merely because our nation spends the most
on the military and the police force.
And that's why we feel safe.
or this
do we get consumed by laws and Supreme Court
Justices and political victories as
if those things are going to control the future.
It's trusting our own power instead of trusting God.
I'm not saying those things are bad. I'm saying those things become
the source of our comfort and our security.
Now you might be sitting there thinking about this and like well, well the world is Raging
against us shouldn't the church Fight Fire With Fire?
I completely agree with you.
It's just that the fire with which the church fights is
the fire of prayer fasting serving humility.
Loving our enemies generosity refusing
to retaliate carrying our crosses.
Because second Corinthians 10:4 says the weapons of our Warfare are
not of the flesh but have divine power
to destroy strongholds.
See man-made fire.
Will just end up burning the house down.
But holy spirit fire is true fire that will actually purify.
And so are we to fight? Yes, we are
to fight but we fight with the weapons of Jesus we fight
with the weapons of the Kingdom. That's how a
holy people shows itself distinct.
That's what Psalm 20:7 says so well
some trust in chariots some in horses,
but we trust in the name of the Lord our God.
nothing else
No worldly power. We ultimately trust
in We Trust In Our God
Yahweh.
So we seek Holiness not.
Worldly power it's second from Micah 5.
We learn we seek Holiness not false religion.
Seek Holiness not false religion. It's all
over the Book of Micah. We've seen it and really it's all over the God's word
as a whole.
That people humans like you and me. We have a terrible
habit towards syncretism.
And what that word means is that it's it's just where we
make up our own religious activity by taking
a little bit of this and a little bit of that and and a
little bit of Yahweh and it's all put together for good measure.
The problem is that fundamental to our faith.
Fundamental to every part of
our faith from Genesis all the way through the end is
the worship of one God.
The one God who is delivered us from slavery Israel.
Literally from Exodus us from sin.
The one God Exodus 20 the very first
commandment. He says you shall have no other gods besides
me.
No mixing. No compromising one
God.
And you might be like sitting there thinking. Okay. Well, I got that one
settled man. That's not me.
I'm not worshiping these other gods. I've got that one taken care
of.
Be careful.
Because the enemy is really subtle.
And he might slip in some deception where you're
blending in false religions with Christianity.
Where you take you take a little of this Hindu
thought?
and a little of this Buddhist thought
a little this Karma and some automatic riding
over here and some some new age mysticism over here
and you sprinkle some Jesus on top of it you call it good.
listen, that's
dangerous
That's why we must.
Just hold fast to the word of God the essential nature
of God's word that we align our
practices and our beliefs with what it says first.
Because there's stuff you're hearing all the time that's gonna be contradictory to that
even though it sounds right.
Because when you make a God in your own image.
When you make a God in your own image what you're comfortable
with that's false religion. Just as much as anything else
is.
Here's a question I've asked.
of my own heart
if your conscience is Never pricked by the
Jesus you worship.
Then it's not the true Jesus. You're actually worshiping.
right if it's never
confront if you're always okay, if you're always right, that's not
Jesus.
Because you're not like him yet.
He's got work to do in your heart. You're still in the flesh is
still there, right? So you have things that he's going to confront
you on he's going to convict you of if it never happens.
Check where you're actually trusting in.
He has called us to be holy people his his possession
his holy people so we have
to purge ourselves of everything that would paint
that picture of separateness.
in the world
or does it just look like everybody else?
But I thought as I was looking at Micah 5, I I thought we
could take a double click on that false religion idea and
take it a level deeper.
And get to a thought that I think maybe maybe
hits us a little more directly.
That we must seek holiness.
not cultural Christianity
as we wait for this Messiah
to fully come
we must seek Holiness set apartness not
cultural Christianity.
Let me Define that before we go any further, so we're not confused what
we're talking about.
a cultural Christian
would be someone who might go through the motions with
the title Christian.
But does not truly adhere to the faith. He
is not their lord.
Even if they say he's their savior.
It's often based on family background or even
location that you live. That's just that's what everybody does.
It's kind of like we saw with Judah a couple weeks ago that
they stood up and said we're okay. We're
we're fine with God why because the temple is
right here. We live right next to the temple. So clearly
we're okay with God just by our location.
It's a similar issue with this cultural Christianity and
really the core issue of this.
Goes to Micah 5 verse 15 where he's
talking about judging Nations, who do not obey.
That's the fundamental issue here
a lack of obedience. It's the
same thing second Thessalonians. 1:8 says that at
the Lord's return he will bring Vengeance on those who do not
know God and on those who do not obey the
gospel of our Lord Jesus.
She listen when we talk about being a Christian.
It's not just a label to apply to your life.
Like OSU Alum or engineer or athlete or
whatever else we're talking about a life-changing
Faith here.
See, this is not just a social club to join for
benefits and for friends. Jesus calls
us to come and die to ourselves.
And here's why this is such a big problem in our world right
now because cultural Christianity causes the world to lose
its picture of who Jesus really is.
Because the church in general looks no
different than the rest of the world does.
divorce rate same
drunkenness is prevalent.
pornography's rampant
abuse is covered up.
Our words on the golf course are very different than the
words. We used in church.
We freely accept sin as if it's no big deal and even
changing our beliefs to to comfort those who are
sinning.
some of the most terrifying scriptures
Are found in Verses?
21 through 23 of Matthew 7
where Jesus says not everyone who
says to me Lord Lord will enter the kingdom of
heaven.
But the one who does the will of my father who is in heaven.
On that day same day. We're talking about many will
say to me Lord. Did we not prophesy in
your name? Do we not cast out demons in your name and
do many mighty works in your name? Did we not look like a believer?
And I will declare to them.
I never knew you.
Depart from me you workers of lawlessness.
It's terrifying.
to think
That you can look like a Believer the entire.
entirety of your life
playing some religious game and
he looks at you on that day and says, I don't know who you are.
I've never had a relationship with you.
You never gave me your life.
So Hear Me friends if this is you if you're playing some religious
game in all of this just stop doing it
if this is some hobby for you stop
It's a terrible hobby. You could waste your life doing this.
You might as well if this is just a game you might as well go play
golf or go to the the lake or whatever else. It doesn't matter. What
you need to do is instead of just mentally agreeing with
some factual information about Jesus. You
need to die to yourself repent and believe in
Jesus.
You can't be good enough.
You can't be religious enough to earn your
salvation. You need Mercy.
Because on our own hear me on our own you and I
are do the Vengeance of God
because we have not obeyed him.
And so verse 15 said every one of us none of us have obeyed him.
And so we're do the Vengeance of God, but Mercy.
Mercy means he does not give you what you deserve.
Because Jesus.
Took that penalty for you on the cross.
He took the wrath of God the Vengeance of God on
the cross in your place. If you repent and believe in
him, he saves you. That's the kind
of Fate hear me. That's the kind of faith that changes you.
I get it. I lived it for 20 years.
To try to to have this this good
enough life and to sprinkle Jesus on
top of everything. I was wanting to do myself. I get that and it's fruitless.
It's exhausting.
This is the kind of faith that changes us
that leads you to then abstain from
the passions of the flesh to live in a way that glorifies God.
That's what faith truly does.
What that means is you don't have to clean it up before you come to
Jesus.
Like don't hear me say that you have to earn your way that you have to obey
where he's not going to love you. No you obey because he already loves
you.
He makes you he makes you I will I will
I he makes you a holy nation Church.
He makes you a holy person one who
set apart and so in that receive it.
Receive it and act like it because of the Gospel.
In light of God's mercy towards Sinners Like You and Me.
And with God's Spirit dwelling inside of us. Let's
be his set apart ambassadors.
For his glory not for ours. Let's show the world.
This is who God is.